I don't understand
this, Ilana.
It's like you have
a thousand socks,
but no underwear
in the underwears drawer.
You don't have
to tell me.
I don't know where
my underwear goes.
That's why I'm always
going commando.
Oh, is this it?
No.
That's my old dictaphone
from high school.
Is a dick phone?
Dic-ta-phone.
Oh, I was...
"Hello? Hello, Dick."
(Ilana's voice on tape)
Great idea number nine.
It's like Facebook,
but just for photos.
(inhaling, exhaling
doing bong hit)
I guess it could be
videos, too,
but mostly photos.
(dictaphone off)
Ilana, you invented
the Instagram.
That's insane.
I bet I was high the last
time I had my remote.
Like, for sure!
Yeah, yeah.
Like, certainly.
Certainly, yes.
Maybe if I get high again
I'll remember where I put it.
Aren't you already high?
I-- I mean,
like, more high.
Is "higher."
"Highest."
♪
Last year, Brooklyn.
My old apartment
on Flatbush.
Living room...
couch.
Sex on the couch.
Bad sex.
Really bad sex.
The worst sex.
Dale!
Eww...
Dale.